I used to want to be a radio DJ when I
was little but now I'm podcaster which
is great because I don't have the voice
to be a DJ I and by the way being a DJ
from what I've heard from people who are
DJs it sounds like it's terrible
business so I'm very happy being a
podcaster because it's more interesting
than then you know being a general
purpose radio DJ to me it's more
interesting it's an easier business to
be and there's no requirement that you
have a great voice I sure as heck don't
and most other podcast I wasn't I don't
know telling people a good voice it
doesn't matter and and I get to talk
about really geeky things so I enjoy
that but I'm already doing that and
generally anything that I want to do you
because I've had a terrible academic
history it usually isn't things that
require certifications and degrees and
long schooling and everything else it's
like well what can I do when I have a
computer and I can make podcast I can
make apps I can write so that's stuff I
do and I am really happy to in it I like
arguing with people sometimes so you
might think lawyer but in reality I'd be
a terrible lawyer because I would make a
bunch of mistakes and I would I would I
would miss a lot of things and so I
think I I would not be good at that I
certainly could not do any kind of
medical field thing because I'm not even
close to you know meticulous and and a
good student enough to do that
so not really no I occasionally think oh
you know it'd be fun to like have a
coffee shop and sell my coffee but then
I don't want to work in a coffee shop so
well I shouldn't own one there's all
sorts of thing like that like III think
I can i can talk myself out of almost
any other job pretty easily
not even close and be well first of all
whatever you think of Apple and their
products at heart they are still a big
company and I know I would not do well
on a big company I just know I I don't
do well doing things I don't want to do
being subservient to other people
playing the politics game to try to get
ahead I am terrible at all those things
and so I know I would I would not get
very far I would be miserable and I
would probably be fired within a couple
of years at most
and and I just I would be terrible at
that job because no matter again no
matter what you think in order to do
well at Apple you have to do well in a
big company because that's what it is
because you're quite idealistic right
and you know I you always want to change
the world for the better
you know it will the technology both for
the better sure surely the best way to
change the technology world for the
better would be on the inside you know
if if I was Tim Cook maybe I could make
the kind of changes I want but if I
let's say I went to go head the podcast
team at Apple what would that really
mean I would be running a team that has
to interact with the iTunes Store
back-end run the whole directory in
addition so you have like these
different departments you have to work
with the server's team and then you have
also the podcast app now is integrated
into the OS you don't you don't download
it separately anymore it's right there
in the OS then you have to work on the
release schedule of the OS and so
there's all these different pressures
you'd have to deal with from within the
reason why the podcast app is not what I
want it to be is not because there's
anybody bad managing it it's because of
the conditions that it has to deal with
are not conducive to what I want
that's on a screen called nitpicky
details every time I do things like this
I think it's a risk and I think maybe
it'll turn off some people and every
time things work but no one really
notice is my job I look back on it kind
of the way I look back on college it's
like it's something